Макс знає декого, хто знає декого,
хто знає декого.
Нові протигази.
Круте відчуття.
Але час тут зупинився.
Я знаю, що вони несправжні, але вони справді мають запах.
Ми спускаємося все глибше і глибше.
Що це за шум?
Сигналізація.
Великий павук. Можеш посвітити на мене, друже? Хвилинку.
Цього ранку ми спустимося глибоко під вулиці Києва, Україна,
у пошуках покинутого бункеру часів "холодної війни".
Зараз мій гід Макс відведе нас туди. Він залишив мені повідомлення вранці:
"Там холодно, волого, тісно
і жорстко."
Ось дещо, про що я дізнався, живучи в цій країні:
коли українці кажуть про щось "жорстко", ти їм справді віриш.
Як тебе звуть?
іПітер.
Ми глибоко спустимося, так?  Еге ж.
Спершу ми поглянемо на найбільший підземний водоспад в Україні.
Потім ми підіймемося на верхівку пагорба і потрапимо в найдовший та найскладніший лабіринт.
Цей веде до однієї з найстаріших систем Києва,
побудованої у 1916 за наказом Миколи II,
який був царем Російської імперії.
А тут холодно, еге ж?
Я взяв світшот.
Що ж, ми спускаємося.
Ось цей твій.
Будь обережний зі своєю головою. Тут багато гострих цеглин та всього іншого згори. Тут можуть бути навіть цвяхи.
Цікаво.
Так. Такі тунелі є всюди.
Я навіть можу скористатися подібною системою під Печерськом,
де знаходяться усі найдорожчі будинки.
Я можу потрапити до закритих підземних паркінгів, які ретельно охороняють.
Вони мають сполучення зі старими радянськими дренажними системами.
І можна просто підняти люк.
Ти можеш пройти під будинками людей і проникнути в їхню приватну власність?
Майже, так?
Зазвичай ми взагалі такого не робимо.
Наша мета - не вриватися до чийогось будинку.
У таких будинках усі двері замкнені. Ми не вриваємось до чийогось житла.
Так, я досить сильний та гнучкий.
Нічого собі, це круто.
Коли це було побудовано?
У 1916. Усе зроблено з жовтої цегли, але цього не видно,
тому що все покрите шаром цементу.
Тут внизу холодно, друзі.
Круте відчуття.
Це найтісніший прохід тут. Обережно з головою.
Я забув попередити тебе про те, щоб ти взяв кепку.
Ми спускаємося все глибше і глибше.
До речі, як ти себе почуваєш? Усе гаразд?
Так, усе добре.
Друзі, я вже доволі довго у такій позі.
Ми вже досить далеко зайшли.
Тут голосно.
Відлуння звідусіль.
Я очікував побачити
по-справжньому брудну каналізацію, яка кишить щурами.
Натомість тут досить чисто.
Можна побачити, що це залізо.
Підходимо ближче? Так.
Навіть можна почути звук води.
Водоспад тут? Так.
Мені тут подобається, друже.
Чисті підземні водоспади Києва.
Уся ця вода тече з іншого тунелю.
Що там?
Це вхід до іншої системи, куди ми підемо.
Тут час від часу утворюються сталактити та сталагміти.
Як у природній печері.і
Можна помітити різні кольори.
Кожні 2 метри - інший колір.
Колір залежить від виду мінералу, який пролягає над нашими головами.
Залізо, сірка, вапно.
Як давно ти сюди спускаєшся?
Вже 10 років.
Ти чуєш цей шум?
Який шумі? Це вода?
Ні. Це метро. Тунель метро у нас над головами.
Багато арок, так?
Усі вони
спрямовують на нас ударні та звукові хвилі.
Тобто буде дуже голосно?
Нам потрібно закрити вуха.
А потім відкрити, лише для того, щоб почути, як відлуння поширюєтся на кілометри під містом.
Навіть ближче до входу можна почути звук вибуху.
Ось це вибух.
Це справжня пригода. Ми у димовій завісі, Максе.
Цей дим зникне за 5 хвилин.
Ви тут влаштовуєте вечірки?  Так.
Тут досить класно, у величезному підземному тунелі.
Глибокі дірки. Тут можна побачити, яка тут чиста вода.
Чи не так?
У великому забрудненому місті неможливо знайти таку чисту воду.
Але нам це вдалося.
Цю мову вже не використовують.
Тут можна побачити традиційні дореволюційні російські літери наприкінці 2 слів: "выходъ", "номеръ".
Цей тунель продовжується і не закінчується.
Як часто буває в Україні,
якщо знаєш когось, хто знає ще когось,
можна отримати доступ.
Це те, про що ти казав? Про якогось старого.
Ні-ні. Зараз ми йдемо до схожої споруди.
Його пильно охороняють. Третє місце охоряняють.
Третє місце найсерйозніше сьогодні.
Бункер, повний протигазів, плакатів, зброї та іншої дурні.
Обережно.
Ці пагорби мають сходи, рівні.
Кожен рівень має власну систему тунелів.
Тобто, ми були в основному під цим схилом.
Так. Ми були в найглибшій системі цієї ділянки.
Ось де ми.
Бачиш? Це наш шлях.
Вилазьмо нагору.
Потрібно подолати багато кущів, щоб дістатися сюди.
Максе, звідки ти знаєш про ці місця?
Я все знаю.
Усе знаєш?
Тобі 25.
Принаймні, я знаю все про підземний Київ.
Волоцюги знають про це місце, приводять своїх друзів. Вони залишають сміття всередині.
Просто черговий день у Києві, так?
Такий Київ, яким ти не очікував його побачити.
Це місто має так багато сторін.
Цього разу буде складніше.
Готовий? Готовий.
Ходімо, заліземо всередину.
Що тут?
Зараз пригадаю шлях.
Здається, сюди. Або сюди.
Що наприкінці цього?
Як почуваєшся? Добре.
Ось настільки тут тісно. Потрібно просто зберігати спокій.
Тут є інший вхід. Ми скористаємося ним.
Гаразд. Розвертаємося?
Так. Розвертаємося і повертаємося до перехрестя.
Гаразд.
Як це виглядає, Максе? Нормально.
Стоп, стоп, стоп. Давай.
Великий павук. Ти можеш на мене посвітити, друже? Хвилинку.
Усе гаразд. Це інтерактивна зйомка.
У цьому щось є.
Я ж казав. Ти хотів щось зовсім не схоже на звичайну прогулянку.
Я хотів отримати глибокі знання Макса.
Але й тут щось пішло не так, тому що тепер ти не знаєш, де ми, так?
Ось цей  - рядянський, з цементом,
А цей - царських часів, зроблений з жовтої цегли.
Можна побачити маленькі отвори для свічок, так?
Це для свічок? Як ти вважаєш?
Зараз ми проходимо під Старим містом.
Поблизу Арсенальної.
Це круто, друже!
Ось для чого ми робили все це.
Насправді не дуже видно, але розміри неймовірні.
Приємно мати вільний простір. Це точно.
Вдихнути повітря.
Це було ніби тренування. Ми йшли сюди 30 хв.
Ми запустимо тут феєерверки?
Це буде вперше, ти зможеш
сховатися тут, а я тут.
Стій, не рухайся.
Що тут? Ти підіймешся сюди? Так.
Ти можеш лізти вгору так, щоб світло потрапляло в камеру.
Друзі, це досить
незвичайно, це дух пригод.
Не знаю, чи у багатьох містах є щось подібне.
Впевнений, що є, але що стосується доступності
та всього такого.
Макс казав, сюди не варто спускатися сюди влітку, бо якщо починаються дощі,
ці місця затоплює.
Я запитав Макса: "Хіба зараз не літо?"
Він сказав: "Так, але не хвилюся"
Тому я йому повністю довірився.
Ближче.
Ось ми вже майже дісталися до верхівки.
Нічого собі, ось весь шлях.
Не для тих,
у кого клаустрофобія.
але якщо вам не вистачає пригод, такі місця дуже круті.
Що ще круто тут, то це те, що тут є усі ці маленькі секретні ходи.
А потім ми підемо до ядерного бункеру.
Макс сказав, що про нього нікому невідомо.
Туди складно потрапити.
Але є один старий, з яким він знайомий. Ось так ми отримаємо доступ.
Це наступна зупинка.
Що ж тепер ми подолали 3%.
3% усього цього.
3% усіх тунелів у місті? Так.
Оце було тренування. Було глибоко.
Тепер найцікавіша частина.
Ми пробираємося крізь ліс.
Виходимо до дороги.
Отже, основна причина існування цих тунелів -
стікання води, щоб схил не руйнувався.
Так. Щоб усі ці дороги залишалися на місці, усі споруди, побудовані над парками, пам'ятки.
Усе залишається на місці.
Тому що пагорб тут досить крутий.
Дивовжно, що цар був таким завбачливим.
Це ж почалося за часів царя.
Що ж, ми заходимо. Секретне місце.
Це надсекретно.
Ніхто ззовні не знає, де ми.
Макс знає декого,
хто знає декого, хто знає декого.
По-українськи. Ми всередині.
Це радянський бункер часів "холодної війни", так?
Це справжня знахідка.
Це справжній бункер часів "холодної війни",
повний обладнання, повний павуків.
Ми заходимо через екстренний вихід.
Ми не використовуємо головний вхід.
Чорний вхід.
Але ж це посеред міста.
Посеред міста, за контейнерами зі сміттям.
Поруч з квартирними будинками та парком.
Але я хотів би сказати,
що це незвичайний бункер.
Чому? Тому що він був сконструйований як підземна лабораторія.
Всередині є величезні клітки Фарадея.
Ти знаєш, що це? Ні.
Клітка Фарадея - це ніби спеціальна ізольована кімната, зроблена з металу,
щоб захищати різне електронне обладнання від радіомагнітних хвиль, наприклад.
Тому що після ядерного вибуху
виникає електромагнітне поле,
яке може спричнити проблеми з електронними пристроями.
Усе вимикається.
А це Інститут статистики.
Тут вони мають власну підпільну лабораторію.
Величезні старі комп'ютери з перфорованими картками, а не програмами.
Після ядерного вибуху, вибухова хвиля проникає
в цей тунель.
Потім ці броньовані двері зупиняють хвилю, а ці панелі
закриваются
і відкриваються після зниження амосферного тиску.
Подивися, як гарно. О, так.
Час тут зупинився.
Коли це місце
звільнилося? У 1991?
Так, правильно.
Найпізніше - у 1995.
Тобто вони просто покинули усе це? Так.
Скільки ще таких у Києві?
400 бункерів, але лише 20% підтримують діяльність.
Що це за шум? Сигналізація. Зламана сигналізація.
Вода руйнує систему сигналізації.
Це вода? Справді.
Усі кабелі.
Погляньте на це.
Це інструкція для того, щоб одягатися у разі ядерної атаки?
Упізнаєш наше спорядження на сьогодні? Так.
Подивися на дату.
1977. Тут ти торкаєшся справжніх матеріалів, не в музеї.
А у справжньому місці.
Сьогодні досить складно знайти
такий недоторканий покинутий бункер, не зруйнований, де щось досі збереглося.
Підпільна електростанція.
Сяє у темряві. Флуоресцентний.
Скільки людей тут могло б бути?
До 500.
Тут сотні старих документів.
Папки з документами.
Тобто, після розпаду СССР усі ніби зникли.
Усі співробітники?  Так.
Але тут можна знайти й сучасні документи,
датовані 2010-2011 роками.
1981. Що це за документ?
Усі вони стосуются цієї фабрики, зарплатні робітників.
Знаєш, що таке "п'ятирічка"?
Це план на 5 років.
Як виконується п'ятирічний план. Плани. Інститут планування - плани тут.
До речі, я не жартую. План на 5 років. Тепер усе поховане тут навіки.
Опломбовано.
Краще використовувати це світло, воно менш яскраве. Ходімо.
Американська
ядерна зброя.
Цей постер зроблений власноруч.
Підійди, доторкнися. Він розфарбований. Зроблений руками.
Одяг, уніформа - усе досі тут.
Сьогодні у Києві майже неможливо знайти покинутий бункер, який так добре зберігся.
Легкодоступний.
Схожі умови можна знайти лише під заводами і фабриками, які досі повністю під охороною.
Так, але не такий вже й легкодоступний.
Тобі потрібно знати, як сюди проникнути.
Так. Та все ж я можу сюди проникнути.
Чоботи...
Чоботи, лічильники Гейгера...
Нові протигази. Новісінькі.
Прямо з 1986.
Можливо, вони знадобляться нам для коронавірусу.
Я бачив людей у них
кілька місяців тому.
Абсолютно недоторкана конференц-зала.
Тут пліснява, тут волого.
Але час тут зупинився.
Яке сюрреалістичне місце.
Тут звучить сигналізація, тут Ленін.
Це пропагандистські плакати.
Грудень, 1994.
Бачиш, кожен стіл належить
певному працівнику.
Це стіл начальника медичної бригади.
Стіл людини, відповідальної за евакуацію.
Тобто, ми просто під цим Інститутом зараз? Так.
Але тепер це бізнес-центр.
Бізнес-центр прямо над нами.
Вони гадки не мають, що тут.
Що тут відбувається?
Медична підготовка. У них тут червоний хрест.
До речі, це стіл начальника медичної бригади.
Що тут?
Це те, що залишилося від камери Фарадея.
Дивися, тут залишилися лише якісь панелі.
Але усе інше, інші шари були зруйновані або розкрадені мародерами.
Ким?
Мародерами, злодіями.
Це головна лабораторія.
Тут усюди стояли комп'ютери.
Підземне море.
Там був бруд.
Що це?
Коробка з сюрпризом.
Коробка з частинами тіла людини.
Це для медичної підготовки?
Ноги, язики.
Я знаю, що вони несправжні, але вони справді мають запах.
Ось що має запах.
Що це?
Це сумка
зі знезаражуючою рідинною.
Старі пляшечки,
трохи порошку.
Потрібно приготувати спеціальну знезаражуючу речовину
й очистити свій одяг після повернення із зараженої зони.
Це справді цікавий день, Максе.
Незвичайний день. Але у цьому місті не буває нормальних днів.
Більшість цих будівель можна з'єднати.
Ось так ми підійшли до найцікавішого місця.
За стіною можна знайти жовтий кабель.
Можна знайти такий самий кабель
всередині вентиляційної шахти з правого боку.
Коли ламаєш стіну, щоб дістатися сюди з іншої кімнати.
Тобто, це система сигналізації?  Так.
Навіть у вентиляційній шахті їх повно.
Ніхто не зміг би навіть проповзти крізь вентиляцію у цю кімнату.
Ми застрягли?
Що ж, це все, друзі. День під Києвом.
Круте,
Круте відкриття.
Я досить стомлений і пошарпаний.
Гарна робота, Пітере. Молодець.
Дякую, друже.
У Києві стільки всього відбувається на поверхні, але під земелею...
До сьогодні я не знав, що це цілий новий світ.
Макс - це людина, яка вам потрібна, якщо ви туди збираєтеся.
Я залишу посилання на твій Інстаграм в описі.
10 років займаюся цим. Нам справді є що показати.
Це було неймовірно.
Дякую, що завітав. Не кожен може це зробити, але у тебе все вийшло.
Ти вперше побачив справжній феєрверк під землею.
Кілька шалених вибухів.
Покинутий бункер. Ти добре тримався.
Місце з матеріалами ядерного розпаду.
О так.
Що ж, друзі. До наступного відео!
Далі буде ще більше про Київ.
А потім ще більше про Україну. Я буду в авто і подорожуватиму до інших місць.
До зустрічі!